[Applaudissements]
les premières estimations sont tombés
emmanuel macron vient d'être élu
président de la république
il obtient plus de 65 % des voix la fête
peut commencer pour les militants yves
binois du mouvement en marche on est
euphorique
c'est génial c'est vraiment c'est pas
marine le pen qui bat c on a on a contré
le le fascisme entre guillemets on est
super content
les compétences des travailleurs versée
voilà les parties faille est parti de
rien il est devenu président volant je
suis ravi de l'espoir qu'ils portent
quel soir d'unités un espoir que des
moments si l'europe
dans les yvelines le candidat en marche
obtient plus de 77% des suffrages
un meilleur score qu'au niveau national
que l'on retrouve aussi à montigny le
bretonneux
avec près de 84% des voix de quoi
satisfaire les marcheurs pour leur
mobilisation
c'est très très fort ce qui a pu se
faire on a travaillé dur mais surtout
quand je pense à tous ces bénévoles qui
nous ont suivi quand même des premiers
jours qui ont cru en nous et qui sont
battus partout aujourd'hui hier encore
était ce qu'a réalisé madame bacon c'est
justement de permettre un bon français
de croire en nous et de recroise dans
cette belle dame qu'est la cinquième
régulier et d'aller à la soupe
l'évolution démocratique certains
militants quittent rapidement le qg
yvelinois direction l'esplanade du
louvre pour célébrer ce moment inédite
dans l'histoire de la vème république un
candidat élu président en ayant créé son
mouvement politique il est un peu plus
d'un an
tout le monde nous disait que c'était
impossible
melvin le connaissez pas la france merci
de votre confiance
merci du temps que vous avez donnée
merci de votre engagement à toutes et
tous des remerciements destiné notamment
aux militants du modem
durant la campagne il se sont engagés
aux côtés d' emmanuel macron notamment
dans les yvelines
mais le soutien du modem et entier au
bien au contraire on est plus motivé que
jamais pour l'aider à réussir son projet
entre les candidats en marché avec comme
modèle avant cette alliance pour les
législatives des postes ministériels
pourraient être attribués à des membres
du modem
emmanuel macron devrait dévoiler le nom
de son premier ministre et la
composition du gouvernement
lundi 15 mai